[Music]
welcome back to care for boys everybody
the land of very very careful gentlemen
yeah oh i think we take pride in being
white hopefully this isn't some kind of
hate symbol in the future
oh see he's already turned it into a
hate thing dude we're gonna get canceled
for that mart ruined it in 24 seconds
no he i would say like right now let's
grab the hamburger but in five years it
could evolve to grab him by the ball you
don't even know still ruin true by the
false this angle it's like it's like
30 seconds and then we say balls yeah
it's over don't be throwing a wii in
there like that
that's what we were representing when we
held up our hands we were representing
grabbing by the ball i'm included in
this as well
solidarity i have i have a question i
actually was wondering about this last
time we were here but i didn't get to
ask you guys but when
you were single
and a girl hit on you how did you turn
her down oh wait that's really supposing
a lot you were single oh we got hit on
all the time yeah this assumes that we
get hit on you guys remember all which
time okay which time was it yeah like i
got like three in my head
because it's very because it's kind of a
it's already a rare thing that guys are
turning down a girl that's hitting on
them but like well no what's going on
really is that i didn't know that she
was hitting on me until later in that i
mean by later i mean like five to ten
years later
i have more examples
of being blind or just cloud outlets
than actually being hit on like
blatantly and then refusing oh ryan's
also supposing that there's [ __ ]
[ __ ] being thrown at him all the time
yeah we're not dancing
so when you guys go down rodeo drive
every day what are the stores you guys
don't like
what the [ __ ]
all of them when i was in high school
this chick pulls me like we're in drama
and in drama club dude you [ __ ]
anything goes basically like everyone's
all over the place
drama dude and so this chick pulls me
into this dark room and i was like what
the [ __ ] going on and i walked out of
there and i was like what was that about
he was mad hands on his hips what was
that about the hell was that about what
do you think she was trying to do
there was no no light in there that's
never happened to any of you guys when
you were single that you realized the
girl was kind of trying to hit on you in
a way not like a stranger on a sidewalk
but like someone like a friend of yours
liked you or something and you weren't
into it and you tried to get out how how
forward was it because when it's clear
and forward then it's like forward
enough for you to realize what's going
on i just ignored her jojo says no
i just say no means no okay and junior
hires his chick named esther
like she's colorado yeah
shout out to esther
yeah i figured
i don't even remember how we started
talking on the phone like every day
and then every day she ended up telling
me that like she would like dance around
and oh yeah like a crush on this guy and
oh cool and then we're just talking
talking it's like the clue's fine it
goes in the direction when you find out
it's it's you you know yeah but then i
still want her to hear that she says and
i'm like who is it like
i don't know who this person is like oh
the first name starts with the b last
name enter they start with the k
that's my birthday
and then she finally like said it like i
like you
and then she hung up because i think she
got
mad at you awkward or like whatever oh
she got shy but then when i actually
heard her say those words to me since i
didn't feel any way towards her i was
like
oh [ __ ] i also didn't know how to react
and then so i'm like i think in my mind
the only way i could deal with it is
okay if i see her at school i don't know
her yeah
you were talking every day and then you
went to pretend i don't know her
jeez man when she spoke to you were you
like just looking straight like do you
hear something
drums and then uh i remember she was
like [ __ ] on the uh
the [ __ ] xylophone xylophone uh
xylophone look at me people said the
bells because we're in the back of the
or in the back of the band right she's
like looking at me
and i'm like
[Laughter]
she's like i tried calling you and
you're like oh my family lost our
landline
as he picks up i think she's trying to
give me those eyes like
so you know we did have a moment on the
conversation like i gave you a big piece
of information like where do we go from
here you know and i'm just like you
don't think it was as simple as like hey
are we still friends or hey you're
missing you're cute idiot
he's like you're not on time look at the
conductor
i love it you just ignore her wait how
did it just all of a sudden change for
you you just didn't feel it anymore i
get it it's awkward after that right
that's awkward yeah i think like because
you don't feel that way were you just
friends why would you talk so damn much
i don't know i was
maybe i was maybe i was lonely you're
talking to bart though what you're a
different breed how many how many
girlfriends had you had before that
moment no i think that that's just like
that it's like a kid doing something
that's like are you dumb but it's like
no you you have to try it the first time
to realize she was friend zoned yeah and
she thought she was having an intimate
moment and you're just like i really
like the conversation no seriously i'm
not just trying to [ __ ] yeah that's why
bart is so literal i did like an [ __ ]
thing but with an innocent intention you
know what i mean yeah and there's this
one other chick that i like too oh here
comes the [ __ ] part though yeah oh
okay we already know what do you mean
just keep going
wait what no
there's another chick i like and then
that's it so i think oh your heart was
with another girl that you weren't
i thought you were about to tell a
different story yeah that's where i was
at as well because of the way that you
presented it no no no no no well the
other there was
another girl
uh
the other girl actually came on to me
too but i was so [ __ ] dumb i remember
in history class shout out to miss
wollman
bart's burning docks and all kinds of
people dude we're sitting in class and i
had a crush on her and i remember in
class she was like you know what i like
to do
i like to practice like making out with
my hand like this what the [ __ ] i
remember that [ __ ] i'm like
girls didn't do that in my mind i'm like
that's
weird and i think you're just too scared
to admit that she's probably trying to
like make advances you know yeah like
maybe we should go to a [ __ ] donut
store after school or get a coke
container
or just practice making out somewhere
else yeah exactly i'm gonna go scam in
the parking lot
but it's just so dumb guys do dumb [ __ ]
like that where they miss such a clear
sign and they have the like the most
insulting response that's pretty [ __ ]
clear dude i just brought i just brought
back a memory where i was talking to
this girl and i wasn't sure if i liked
her that much yet we were just kind of
like chatting a lot
and then she uh invites me to prom and
my first answer was
that [ __ ] is expensive and lame
[Laughter]
i'm like who goes to those things
geez just like my [ __ ] was ready for
you basically
and then i was like dude this girl's
and i was like oh it's not even my
school that's your school why should i
pay to go to your school you know and i
was just like this is so that great
argument that's how [ __ ] cheap i was
bro and get this
she clearly she [ __ ] clearly would
have rode my dick right and i was like
you're like a [ __ ] idiot why would i
go to your stupid prom
dude
cause i'm in high school right take your
dick to prom i'm in high school i've had
a few hand jobs and blow jobs you know
so your season i've had i have had
experience right experience and i
remember specifically thinking at this
moment man
girls are so [ __ ] hard dude like why
are they so like there you go why are
they so sexually like not liberated and
[ __ ] this girl comes over there's a
problem with sexual liberation i used to
have this massive fish remember my
[ __ ] big ass fish tank and my
that [ __ ] was the size of a coffin right
so she knows i love [ __ ] fish
dude this [ __ ] was huge it's like seven
eight feet long i had a i had the
[ __ ] amazon jungle [ __ ] fish yeah
she knew right
i have a bunch of fish of course i love
[ __ ] fish you're like second to sam
woo as far as like
i'm like the nighttime ranch bro in the
back you know what i mean like
all dirty and cloudy
i had okay yeah so picking up lobster
[Laughter]
the water's just gushing like crazy i'm
basically a chinese restaurant all right
all right and so she knows this right so
she goes oh can i like drop something
off i got something for you and i'm like
sick all right what is it and then she
goes oh it's a surprise so she comes
over and she brings over these like four
or five bags of like different tropical
fish
cichlids whatever this girl must have
spent like a couple hundred bucks right
yeah because you love fish bro and then
she dumped it on the [ __ ] fish tank
and i was like oh that's tight dude
while she was like doing that i was like
she's watching her do that and i'm all
when she came into my room i'm like man
she got a cute little butt too and i'm
like damn man why she's so hard again
dude you should do that thing in that
rob schneider movie where she's wearing
a white t-shirt let me put the fish in
for you i should dip your titties into
the dipper and you're staring at her
titty she's so hard to get
[Laughter]
and she basically just left and i was
like damn dude asian girls are so
[ __ ] uptight she just brought over
some fish like you can't win my love
like that like dude what the [ __ ]
that's so funny i think all of our
problem is that none of us were bullied
enough
like you were allowed for some reason to
have a lot of fish without anybody
making fun of you
hey get this you know why
today's video is brought to you by
touche
ice get like the itchiest of buttholes
oh really yeah and my own solution was i
would always like on my public bathroom
i'd get a paper towel i'd make it all
wet and i take it with me into the
bathroom and i wipe my ass i mean after
i use a dry toilet paper then i use a
weapon so that's kind of like your uh
like a baby napkin yeah yeah and i
didn't even know what bidets really were
until i went to japan and i'm like oh
there's this thing that after you if you
poop in the morning and it cleans your
butt then you're not itchy the whole day
i'm like oh man i wish we had one of
these things and it was so cool that
tushy but they sent us one yeah and i
love using it because it's so easy you
don't even need an electrician or a
plumber to install it and you could do
it by yourself in under eight minutes
and it's freaking cool too because you
also save money by buying way less
toilet paper most of it is blasted away
through the water and you just pat to
dry and i've been using it for over five
years now tushy thank you very much
you're very cool very swag so we want
all of our listeners to have clean bums
just like us visit hellotushy.com off
the record to get ten percent off plus
free shipping right now tag us and at
hello she on social media so that we can
celebrate your clean bum with you that's
hillotishy.com off the record for 10
percent off
they were illegal fish
and i used to sell piranhas
and so i was the bad boy old were you at
this time
how old were you at 16 17 i mean it was
high school so was she just feeding your
piranhas or like well i didn't have a i
had a different piranha tank that i sold
piranhas from but yeah my god also the
size of a coffin that's that's the whole
i think that's the whole thing about uh
guys being hit on is they don't know
what's happening and they say something
freaking stupid and then and then
exactly that where right afterwards
you're like dude girls are so
complicated man but then she's looking
at you like you're
the opposite like you're just so [ __ ]
i came over to [ __ ] give you a gift
and suck the [ __ ] out of your dick what
is wrong with you but because they don't
say it it's like with bart saying yeah
we're literal creatures okay some of us
are robots about it but some of us
[Laughter]
we just need to be told a lot more like
right over the head like i like you i
bet you we all have more examples of
blowing off women that probably liked us
100
really then we have of like just
actually refusing girls oh i thought
you're gonna say that we have getting
blown off by women that we like because
i'm like
arguable
we have more examples of blowing off
women than getting blown by women
yeah that is the transitive blow so in
my junior high example
i like another chick right so that kind
of makes sense but then when you like
the chick
and that chick is giving you
reciprocation but you're still too
[ __ ] dumb to see yeah what's
happening that's the part that you're
like god damn wow that's so [ __ ] so
i bet you have a story about that
situation no he told us that story
yesterday in college kind of like he has
a story and he was leading up to it
i'm just trying to bait anthony and
telling us his because he's got a
million problems
man i don't have any i don't have any
good stories uh that are as uh as
piranha as joe over here you know like i
think i think even for me like in high
school i was probably my in terms of
like my uh one of my longer term
girlfriends in high school she's awesome
still but um
i think i was kicking with her every day
for months
and just being like nah she's just a
close friend for like months you were in
denial that she liked you liked you i
don't even
know i think i'm just dumb you know guys
are just dumb it's like if you [ __ ]
give the answer i think even what steve
was saying even if a girl is like i like
you you still might be dumb about it you
might be like i don't know what that
means does she like me though or like
yeah exactly so
i can only attribute it to just being
dumb
and then like and finally we went to go
see one of the um the school plays or
whatever together at like the performing
arts center
and then in the darkness again i totally
think it's platonic for some reason but
then i remember in the darkness being
like uh just in between one of the acts
it's like
finally we're just holding hands out of
nowhere next you know we start kissing
and in my mind
i'm still like does she like me as i'm
like kissing her i'm like i don't get
this
yeah is it me or is it just the moment
yeah i really feel like we're just dumb
you know what i mean until it's like
explicitly
taught to you by experience yeah is that
impostor syndrome
we talked about it for 20 minutes
yesterday and joe's like still not sure
about this
i don't think this is
i think you also hear a lot of horror
stories about guys getting their hearts
broken and if it hasn't happened to you
yet you're afraid that one day you'll be
that guy so you don't want to get your
hopes up even though it's dead obvious
dude i was making out with a chick in a
steven seagull movie
oh just stop right now
no it was called half past dead it was
like his last one that went to theaters
that's dead yeah it was like him in jaw
rule or i think it was dmx or oh yeah
he's [ __ ] hilarious it was yeah
that's exactly what was that and uh so
so we were the only people in the
theater and so we were making out in the
back of the theater and i remember
thinking the whole time and like by the
way stephen's goals like gutting people
and she's like a weirdo
i remember thinking to myself i'm like
man a lot of murder i really hope she
really likes me because i really like
her but it's like you're making out with
her bro you're like laying on top of
each other making out with each other in
an empty theater and you're still
questioning it yeah guys you guys don't
get it for a long time probably wasn't
intimate man yeah exactly because you
don't know because she could have just
stopped talking to you too out of
nowhere that happened like in high
school and [ __ ] with friends oh yeah
yeah i did that to somebody like my
freshman year girl she said i was really
good friends with her and i really liked
her she was really cool and but i only
saw her as a friend
and we hung out all the time and like a
group of friends
and she told me one day that she liked
me that she really liked me i didn't
know what to do
so then
i completely stopped talking to her
there you go busted a bart huh and that
right there dude that's what a lot of
girls ask about they go why do you guys
do that well they're children for one i
felt bad that i didn't like her back
yeah and then that made me feel like oh
yeah i felt this is weird bro like you
should like her back or you don't want
to let her down
yeah kind of i kind of felt like
obligated to like her back but i was
like but i don't like you
like that you could be there at another
point like maybe you're not there yet or
you just didn't like her no i just was
like this is weird now there's probably
also like you guys never verbally uh
actually admitted like hey i don't like
you back you never said that yeah and i
go oh
okay and that's what i did i was like
all right and then i just felt like i
needed stuff too hard that's what i'm
saying i feel like guys are like they
can't say that so instead it's like i'm
just if i'm not around you or if i don't
see you i don't have to say those if
it's the truth it'd be i don't like you
back because i saw you too many times
with eye boogers
that'd be the truth
and that might hurt way more
that's an exclusive report
that's
if in that age you only knew what it's
like to live with a woman
yeah yeah you were so young
well whoa comics unleashed
now here's another um inverse thing so
i'd basically be the evil version of you
where i don't know if this happened to
any of you guys i've heard a lot of
girls ask why guys do this and i was
guilty this many times but have you ever
kind of liked a girl
and then when she finally said she liked
you
you became no longer interested yes
that's a validation thing though i mean
i'm not exactly sure what it is it's the
truth always known it was wrong you
wanted the chase and then once you got
it you're like oh no where did it go
yeah yeah
you're more in love with the pursuit
because of the exhilaration and then
once you get it you're like well then
what is what left is there
the next stage is is
touching each other
fair point fair point
i think there's also fear of commitment
it's not just like the chase and that
glory and then just nothingness after
there's also a fear of like oh [ __ ] now
what what's everything about my life
that's supposed to happen with that you
know yeah i think there's a point in
like young dudes hopefully this is
gone but like you know there's a there's
a point in your age when um
when all the guys know who's trying to
get who and there's just that symbol of
like accomplishment when oh damn you got
her you know but it's not really uh
nobody's giving accolades for wow your
relationship is that great with this
person it's more like dude you got that
girl we're hunting that's dope yeah
you're hunting and you're showing
catches and it's like
that almost takes priority you get so
good at just that and then once it's
time to like move on to the next chapter
it's like oh well i kind of want to just
do this again because i'm so good at
this dude girls do that too i remember
in high school my friend she was like do
you think it's wrong that i want a guy
to like me when i don't even like him
but then i want my friends to think i'm
cool or like you know like that's like a
status almost yeah you always do that
too like oh for sure i think um
i thought she was a shady ass [ __ ]
you're gonna play with this dude's
emotions and they're gonna [ __ ]
commit to you emotionally and then
you're gonna break his heart i like that
she's like i could tell anything to joe
the fish man like who gives a [ __ ] about
joe the fish man he's not gonna do
anything
he's always giving you guys he's a shady
ass [ __ ]
he'll be a real shady ass hey watch me
give this fool some fish here's all
having to pop my hand
the whole thing just
yeah i think i think that's it's a thing
that it's it's unfortunate but it's not
wrong because it is kind of natural to
want to be like yeah but then i think
there's a point where you just kind of
stack them up too that's what i'm saying
i'm not trying to like uh say that it's
right in any way but i feel like human
beings have to test their like emotional
capacity through social experience like
that and it's like
people are going to be in sometimes the
victim and sometimes the you know
perpetrator whatever you know what i
mean but at the end it's like kids
it's like you're a kid but with your
heart you know what i mean so you just
gotta do something and so
i also think that guys i mean like just
p just kids in general don't know
themselves right so like i've plenty of
times convinced myself that i was
completely in love and infatuated with
someone just to know that after we
we [ __ ] or whatever i'm just like oh
wait wait that was just horny
and then like i think that happens a lot
where you just commit and you say all
these things and you're just like you're
not trying to play anybody in the moment
you actually believe it and you're
really believing the [ __ ] that you're
saying because you really think that
you're going to be together forever and
then you do it and you can see clearly
because it comes out of your system and
you're like
you know what
i don't love her yeah and i think that
happens all the time i mean the easiest
way to understand it is if you sometimes
when you're starving you eat stuff you
normally wouldn't choose exactly after
you're done consuming that uh food you
go hey women are not mcdonald's
hamburgers okay dude you're good at
breaking up with you
that's expert level dude he's like dude
i was [ __ ] hungry sometimes you eat
some [ __ ] you never wanted to eat and
you're like okay we could break up i get
it
i understand
it's the same you're just not healthy
for me tell your old man he was cool
though